les analyses n'ont pas fait apparaître
sur les principales molécules de risque
de toxicité aiguë tout ce tout en
feintes ou panache de fumée et polluant
nous en sommes d'accord il n'ya pas là
de toxicité particulière il n'y a pas de
raison de s'inquiéter outre mesure je
n'ai aucun élément qui permette de
penser que les fumées en particulier
serait dangereuse il ya un fort de jez
des productions et pour les particuliers
il est recommandé de l'est pas consommer
de produits sous quatre ministres se
sont déplacés sur place
fermeture immédiate des écoles et pas de
réouverture en attendant le fait qu on
soit sûr effectivement qui n'est plus de
pollution des communications
institutionnelles encore une sans doute
ce soir qu'il évoquera le point du
travail mais en même temps on peut
comprendre une forme de psychose qui
s'est installée dans une population faut
la transparence totale
rien ne sera caché tout ce qu'il ya au
service des analyses seront communiqués
à la population sans communiquer à tout
le monde peut se réjouir du fait qu'il
n'y a eu aucun blessé grave
et effectivement il ya une odeur qui est
très dérangeante mais il n'y a pas eu de
problème sanitaire
je ne dis pas que les odeurs ne sont pas
gênantes encore une fois je vous dis
simplement ce que disent les analyses
qui m'explique qu'elle ne sont pas
nocives j'ai évidemment comme tous les
habitants dron dit la ville polluée je
vais pas commencer à nier l'évidence il
y a de toute façon des parlementaires
qui veulent une enquête parlementaire et
je trouve ça très bien